everyone it's mikalos and this is the
orderflows market analysis for July 18
2017 stocks ended up the day kind of mix
a little bit lower actually um money
moved out the dollar dollar Index was
down about a half a percent and you know
crude crude was kind of steady as well
so uh let's jump into it you know brief
disclaimer this presentation is for
educational and informational purposes
only should not be considered a
solicitation to buy or sell a Futures
Contract or make any other type of
investment decision a Futures Trader an
investor could potentially lose all or
more than the initial investment rate
risk capital is money that can be lost
without jeopardizing one's Financial
Security or lifestyle only risk Capital
should be used for trading and only
those with sufficient risk Capital
should consider trading past performance
is not necessarily indicative of future
results again the tools I use in this
are the order flows Trader footprint
chart and I talk about the Delta scalper
now we're making a change in the Delta
scop we're still testing it I'll show
you a couple charts a little bit later
um basically we just made a modification
and to sort of filter out some of the
the trades that I wouldn't normally take
um so you know hopefully this this week
we'll get it uh get it released get it
out to people that already have it it's
it's quite
uh quite to change um you'll be
pleasantly surprised when you see the
charts um you just really quick I'll
just show you the Delta scoper what I
mean um before I get into the orderflow
stuff um you again this is on a normal
um a normal bar chart but you I like to
use the BART TR when I'm testing and
what the Delta scoper does is it reads
the order flow it reads the Delta and
the price action that's going on in the
bar and okay so this is going back to
you know basically yesterday the reopen
um around just after 4 in the morning it
gave a sell signal up here around 2459
it sells off all the way down to 51 gets
a Buy Signal makes a nice little
rally um this is around you know just
after the cash open a little bit later
9:15 you got a sell sells off does come
back up here another sell signal kind of
sells off before it rallies back this is
10:00 um 11:24 you got this little buy
here and then uh just before the close
you got to sell here so you know okay so
you got a loser here you know this one
yeah maybe you know if you're trailing
your stop maybe you you could have got
something out of it um this one probably
would have stopped you out but you know
again you know I mean look at this you
got you you got a nice winner this is
you know eight or nine points you know
points not ticks points and then here
you know probably another four or five
points here another you know before it
starts coming back up you know maybe
getting short somewhere up here and you
know you're trailing you're sto and it
starts coming back up here so again
maybe another four points so you know
even though you have a loser here a
loser you know this one's borderline you
know again if you're trailing your stop
maybe you're breaking even um and this
one is a loser here so you know loser
we'll call this one loser we'll call
this one loser but then you got you know
you got three winners nice winners so
you got small
losses 1 two three but you got three
nice winners right it's only say well
you know your your win percentage is 50%
yeah well you're getting you know 3:1
4:1 5:1 risk to reward ratio you know so
you're you're losing a point here but
you're getting you know Five Points here
you're getting five four points here
you're getting eight points here is here
you lose maybe a point here you lose
maybe a point this one's probably break
even honestly and this one you're you're
losing a point so would you would you be
happy to lose a point to get five back
of course you would um you know everyone
always talks about oh you got to have
winning percentage don't necessarily
think of winning percentage unless you
put it in context
with you know what your winning trades
are yeah sure you're losing you know you
got 50% you only have winners but you
know your your winners are two three
four times what your losers are but um
but
anyway I'll jump into some of this uh
into some of these order flow chart
really quick um I said you know I said
it was kind of a boring day in the
equities and I'll get to the equity
shortly let's talk about the euro
currency really
quick I think it was the euro currency
yeah you this this bar
here you this High okay so you know
what's going on up here right you got
all these buying and balances in this
bar right off the high and the bar turns
down you you have this sort of shooting
star Candlestick and you know think
about what's going on right this is the
benefit of using order flows you can you
know see what's being aggressively
traded at what prices are being
aggressively traded so you're come up
here you're making new highs new high
here you got Divergence it fails comes
back up makes a new high then makes you
know a third new high here over this
this little period from 8:30 836 to 9:00
so you know people are coming in you
know they're saying hey you know we're
grinding higher and people are being
attracted to the market at these new
highs and then they're getting
aggressive and they start buying it and
you know they're very aggressive and all
of a sudden we can't go any higher right
we next bars lower start making a run
back up here you get a single print and
then the market sells off but you know
up here it's it's when you you see this
quite regularly at the ends of moves is
you get the red bar you got the buy and
balances up here you know these are the
people that are late to the party
they're trying to you know catch this
move they're thinking hey you know what
I missed my chance got to get in and
they're getting in they're very
aggressive and you know they're they're
buying outpaces the selling but then
what happens is you know once these guys
are are done buying right you know it's
demand coming in here from wherever
retail Traders you know I don't want to
say it's retail Traders I I don't know
for for certain but you know you see it
time and time again where it's people
are coming in after you're making a move
and they're getting aggressive they're
buying up here near the high we've all
bought the highs and then literally the
market turns around right on us as as
soon as we bought the high and and
that's what's happening up here and in
the order flow you can see it you know
we came back up within a tick of this
high and then you sold off so you know
these are you know like the the week
Longs so to speak you know these guys
are buying it here all of a sudden
they're waiting the Market's coming back
up they're sitting on it thinking hey
you know what now we're making that move
back up doesn't happen you know all
these buyers everyone that's getting
long up here realize and all the other
smart Traders realize that hey you know
what we're not going higher this was
sort of this was a a I'll say a false
high but this is kind of a you know a
weak run after we made this new high up
here that it can't sustain it and then
you know then we sell off down here and
then you I say sell off but we know we
sell off from the
uh 20 area down to you know just above
you know around 11 or 12 um you know
eventually we do go a little bit lower
here but um you know we couldn't sustain
this move that's the important thing is
you couldn't sustain this move on the
move back up but is really telling in
here you got the aggressive buying you
know you see these buying imbalances in
this bar at this High you expect the
market to go higher and it doesn't you
know that that should be telling to you
that hey you know what this high is
probably going to hold because the
buyers just aren't there anymore to move
the market higher and then even when you
get back up here you got the single
print of one lot you got the ratio um
again it's it's telling you of price
rejection up here because you're not
seeing these buyers anymore you know
where are your aggressive buyers they're
gone now I'm going to show you um the
bond
chart because it's it sort of plays
along this line of I think it was the
bonds the aggressive buying um here it
is at the high so this was the bonds
this morning this is a four range chart
and okay so you know
sort you know so we have our high here
we hit the high here you got a ratio U
no Divergence still positive Delta comes
right back up and then you take out the
high you take out the high with the
stack buying IM balance you know three
buying IM balances very strong Delta now
you got a Divergence in a ratio again to
me this is very bearish but it's coming
one is coming right on the back of your
strongest positive Delta of the morning
and a stack
imbalance now normally I'm not a big fan
of stacked imbalances however when
they're taking out
highs I like come um you know if we hit
our high here and come off then you get
stacked in Balance I don't like it as
much but when you're making new highs I
love to see stacked imbalances you know
to me that's a sign that um there's
strong buying past the high because when
you're taking out there's the difference
right if it's a stacked in balance a
little bit below the high you know again
it could be some people coming in late
to the market but if it's at the high
you're breaking out you know I I used to
be a big big breakout Trader um I used
to love to buy Breakout
um but they don't always work right but
when you're breaking out with aggressive
buying stacked imbalances you know to me
it's stronger um as opposed to you know
you get the imbalance maybe you know uh
a few ticks lower going into the high I
I don't put the same weight into it as
when it breaks the high
now so we got this stack bind inbalance
at the high which is important then you
got you know Divergence and a ratio two
bullish things to me this is you know a
go-to trade I I take these things every
day um but it's coming back into the
Stacked buying imbalance here right you
got this it draws out this
Zone
and you know you come down here you get
another buying bance so you got the
aggressive buyers in here again you know
so you're coming back down into this
area where you had aggressive buying
earlier and aggressive buying is
appearing again you got you know here
and here and this stack buying and
balance is holding so you know even
though this is bearish
I'm still running back into a bullish
sign you know we can't I don't think
we're going to get past this get any
lower past this um stacked imbalance
it's holding it's holding so you know
this is one of the things you got you
run into sometimes is you run
into um you know conflicting things and
you it's it's one of those things
sometimes it's not easy you know because
you know if you're you're trading
sometimes you got everything lined up
right like all the planets aligned and
then one thing comes out opposite and
you know you'll think well I've got 10
things stacked you know in his favor
telling me to buy but I got one thing
telling me the opposite you know the 10
you know it's 10 against one you know
the 10 should win but you know it's that
one thing you know the one thing that
that runs contrary sometimes that really
just kills the whole trade so you know
again you know you're coming up in here
you got a bullish sign you know the
stack buying a balance just past the
high
and then you got a bear sign you've got
you know the Divergence and a
ratio okay so it's like you know you
know two fists you know going against
each other you know it's a tug of war
and then what do you get in the next bar
it's why you the next bar this bar here
at 755 is is crucial you know what's it
going to do are we going to break
through the Stacked in Balance you know
is the buying going to be here or not
and basically and here you see it it's
showing up yeah you got the imbalance
you got the imbalances and it holds we
rally back up to the high and we make
new
highs um I said okay equities uh snps
says quiet day in the snps let me just
find my chart
here give me a second here make sure I
got the right chart a four range chart
chart uh okay let's pull it in
here I got to clean up some of my charts
here
um okay so it was this it was this three
in a row you I I talk about three in a
row trades you got ratio ratio
ratio the Red
Bar pullback in between these two
pointer controls uh this one and this
one which you do and then you rally so
you know what do you got you know it's a
continuation trade so you know we have
our low here swing low rally up rally up
almost got a three in a row here don't
get it you know this one's 17 um then
you got ratio ratio and then you get it
here Boom 1 two 3 again which is telling
you the Market's moving you're seeing
some price you know rejection below
These Bars and you're looking so you got
the green bar one two three you got
bullish ratio bullish ratio bullish
ratio
fourth bar in look for the Red Bar the
pullback between these two poter
controls this is where you'd be getting
in here your stop would be just below
this and then yeah you get it you get
you know it's not a stacked imbalance
you get three buying imbalances in this
bar another two here and then you just
looks like it's just going sideways on
you and then later you know you get this
nice pop up up uh up to the
close Okay so thanks for watching this
video uh to learn more about trading
software using this presentation how you
can profit from orderflow visit my
website www. orderflows
docomo I'm still uh still we're still
testing the new version of the Delta
scalper but um you know early uh early
results do look nice so um you know
watch watch my YouTube channel over the
next day or so um for for another video
on the Delta scalper when I get enough
charts um printed or you know when I get
enough good examples I say good examples
when I get enough examples um you know
we're testing it over many different
markets different time frames different
chart types you know range barss minute
base charts um you know just to uh you
know make sure it's robust and you know
because you know a a style of trading
should work over different markets right
I mean you know you shouldn't just have
you know for a way of tradeing you know
it shouldn't just be specific to One
Market you know I mean if you know how
you trade you know
crude you know should also apply to how
you trade minis or bonds or or euro
currency you know if something is Tailor
Made For One Market um you know it's not
going to be robust and he probably not
going to stand the test of time so you
know we're Delta scalper was was good
originally you know I know I know people
that were trading it you know and build
trading systems around it and you know
right now we're just uh just refining it
to um you know find you know I say
better trades but you know just sort of
you know get rid of some of the the
types of Trades that I I wouldn't take
you know there are trades I I don't like
to take and know here are Dax really
quick Dax one minute chart um you know
Dax
moves pretty quick and if you're on the
right side of Trades you know boom this
is what can happen you know you're
buying it here next thing you know it's
30 points
higher you know so it it's giving you
some nice trades now here was a sell
unfortunately gave you a buy here before
it fell over um you know here's a nice
little sell here's some
buys and it doesn't catch every single
move but you know what if if you can
catch you know a move like this from um
you know 80 82 83 84 85 all the way up
to 15 you know you only need to catch a
few of those yeah you could deal with
getting stopped out small stops here
here um you know but if you catching
moves like this that are you know 25 30
points and you're you're just losing
Five Points on you know on on these
losers like here's another one you know
if you
can you somehow manage this trade you
know right on the next bar it taks lower
before it makes this nice move up um you
know if you catch this move from 405 all
the way up to the 420s you know that
that's a nice trade you know here's a
nice little sell before it turns around
here's another sell this is already
after the cash closed but um you know
that's just a that's just a preview you
know just a preview again you know it's
not every trade is going to be winning
trade don't don't think for a second
that this picks every single trade as as
a winner no but what you got to do is
you manage the losing trades right you
get stopped out okay look for the next
trade you know it's not the end of the
world what you want to do is take your
small losses here but catch the nice
winners like this you know sure you get
stopped out here sure you get stopped
out here but you know you got a nice
winner here you here you got a decent
winner before it gives you a buy I don't
know know this one may have stopped you
out you know when you get in on the next
bar this is a one minute chart you know
it does tick lower before it turns
around goes up but again you know if you
could catch you know Big Winners and
keep your losers small I mean that
that's the whole point of trading right
keep your losers small and let your
winners ride so if you got a way that's
going to catch you nice moves like this
you
know then you know then happy days so
anyway guys uh I won't keep you on here
any longer I said you know I'm working
on another video for the Delta scalper
iy hope to get out um and just show you
guys a lot of examples on on the types
of Trades I don't want to get into it on
this one otherwise this will be an hour
long so thanks everybody and you know
hope to have the trading room back up
again tomorrow so bye-bye